curry curry oh you wanna do this [ __ ]
bury me yeah it says bear meat hey guys
its it oh my god so loud
hey guys I think I am in Japan right now
specifically Tokyo
I'm actually here at tasty Japan this is
red I'm red red and I are actually going
to be filming this video together we are
going to try to make a two course meal
using stuff I find from vending machines
ideally maybe three but I don't know do
you think I'll be able to find a lot of
stuff snails
yeah there's a lot of unique vending
machine in Japan so I'm gonna go hunt
down these vending machines now because
you ever stay and work yeah okay alright
so I will see you later see you later
alright bye
we are hunting down some vending
machines and we just found one it says
comp about something a popular soup in
Japan it's really nice there's another
one here it's red bean ooh that sounds
good yeah we usually eat it during that
will show katsu though which is New
Year's time well if you say it's good I
have to get it oh my god it's hot oh
they're both hot and I just found this
really interesting machine
I don't know it's a
I know the mystery gift for woman this
is my seven year now thank you they keep
Japan you said there was a node n
vending machine yeah beautiful enough it
literally says only five minutes view
for twenty minutes I finally found the
Odin vending machine I know it existed
I've never actually seen one before but
he knew of it people talk about it
Oh Amos it is famous I think this is
like a meal in itself right tell you all
the ingredients they have inside so they
have durian cider
I love Darion so you do yeah you don't
have to get it and then I make you try
it
Wow you can show that you and me okay so
a prime mission is like really creepy
vending machine place that we're now
close to are you ready I'm not oh you
ready no you see creepy oh no we're here
this is a photo booth this is a photo
booth and then what is this
No
morning
this is not a bathroom if you pee or
poop here doesn't matter if you're a
male or female they will not be showing
their face driver don't pee in poop
don't do it these look pretty clean up
you know I don't know it's just a little
scary there's another popcorn machine in
here if you stopped open out there was
dirty whoa is that snails 69 yen that's
like around 4:15 u.s. dollars yeah it's
at 6:30 it's good chicken like a toy
yeah
chicken whoa okay I'll get that keep on
feeling like somebody's gonna jump me
scared sausages nice carrots
Oh carrots I sold out there's like two
locks on this and the chain do you think
there's a body inside oh my god you get
eggs and coconut Mel well that's pink
salt
Epping soap curry curry Oh
sit bury me yeah it says bear meat think
about it here - that's a candle candle
let's begin like a lot of earthquake and
there was typhoon so yes that
electricity it cuts off we shall have it
just in case meat sauce meets us without
the pasta yeah Oh interesting back at
this first machine because feel like we
should get the bear hurry there's only
one oh wow
all right guys you've got it bear and
it's not expired so I'll make somebody a
tasty Japan hey like such an adventure
because we're like making already didn't
know a lot of mystery boxes here - on
those boxes they have like different
stories this one's new this one's new
this musics treating you let's do it
they really wrap this up for boxes
weekend's wait wait wait there's a
marked location in here see that creepy
vending machine so creepy
check there's one more place we want to
hit up though not to a vending machine
it is kind of far from here but we're
gonna go because it's worth it right if
we're worth it
let's go we finally found it we'll
finally found it you've never seen one
of these no no girl so many kind Hunico
miso soup miso soup and this is dry not
though
is that not so doughnut why should we
buy it I don't want another miso soup
not the donuts have you ever seen lots
of donuts before I've never seen before
[Music]
that's a lot these are all from vending
machines I didn't carry and I walked I
think we went to like five different
districts literally went north and then
back to the office and my arms are so
sore
what really not though Michel told me so
scuri not told me so not a little bit it
was so cool
Keep Calm yes have you heard of that
like a really creepy corner where
there's like it's like the creepy
vending machine actually oh where is it
you know what I lost it
nevermind I was gonna say this was
actually wrapped in like Oh like this
what yeah neato sauce the pasta
Oh corridor oh yeah where did you get
this do you know what this mean
great yeah very very car you come on
Iggy Toby Oh consomme soup it oh yeah I
used to drink this one
Oh corn potage yeah it is why is that
popular - Oh Maria yeah my favorite they
would this idiot this one is I always
drink this when I was a kid you're
shaking yeah
okay hootie-hoo do you say 200 don't
have not oh no that's it
yeah the way she did this place same
ways not though not go oh we can save
dessert for later but I think all of
this
[Music]
we thought we would only do like one
recourse me about what we've actually
done too and then we use ice and pasta
because they didn't come with it and we
wanted to keep it true to the original
dish I will say though when we were
pouring it out of the cans like the bear
courier you put it out and it was just
like goop I'm excited oh my god it
smells exactly like dude I know okay oh
go my miracle yes si me meal Oh it
screaming Cheers the dreams still in my
mouth so uh hmm really great really good
this is really good I feel like all the
kids are gonna love ya there's nobody
who can possibly not like this
so shoot first and then side dishes side
dishes and manage tomorrow this is so
good
it's not I cannot so not robots tastes
like a not oh it smells off because of
the fermented oh yeah I think but like
when you drink it it just tastes like so
this is really good I think normally
it's a little more bouncy right this one
I think because it's been in the soup
for so long it's just like soft
oh yeah the flavor is great it's just
that the texture is alive tell me how to
eat this oh I just burped in my mouth
and it tasted like dirt you know more
you mix the natto you get like a mommy
oh really I've heard so many things
about this thing I think it started out
okay like started out like I could get
them mustard oh yeah I'm getting used to
the texture a little interesting mmm
really good
yeah soon it was it I thought it's gonna
be like a vending machine quality yeah
but it's not I like it
it's like a little more stringy the
texture but it's not bad the flavor is
really good this just looks like it came
from a restaurant the bear curry hmm
what really that's good can you taste
the bear I can destroy about this like I
can tell that it's not that we regularly
meet
mmm great yeah we're ready so we're
gonna finish it and then we are going to
go and make dessert yes and these are
time desert time bunch of desserts here
yes so we're gonna try and build layers
it's done it's just smells like vanilla
pudding at this point it just came out
like a baby food actually first try it
no not though oh my god I'm so scared
this is really good
yeah oh this is not what I was expecting
what did you expect I thought it was
gonna be a pace Oh No
I just gonna donut on top and coffee
today yeah yeah you did hey yeah
much of the house is great it's really
good
what is the vending machine India
Japanese judo home bike judo hum by keep
our faith there's no harm I keep ahead
[Music]
well you did it then heels turned out
great
I think if we presented it to some
people they probably wouldn't even be
able to know I hope you guys like this
look forward to our other collaboration
videos and uh see y'all then buddy bye
[Music]
you
[Music]